[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Before we begin,
though, there's
one of the things
that we're experimenting
with at Next '18 this year.
And that's bringing part of
our internal Google culture
to the conference.
So whenever we do
presentations at Google,
we have this thing
called a Dory.
And the idea behind
a Dory is sometimes
you're sitting in a presentation
and a question pops up
at the beginning of
the presentation.
And by the time you get to
the end of the presentation,
you're like Dory the
fish where you kind of
forget what your question was.
So you can put your
questions into a portal
as you think of them.
And then other people
using the portal
can vote the questions
up or vote them down.
So I'm going to try.
If you're thinking of
questions as I'm presenting,
put them into the Dory.
I'll answer some
of them at the end.
But I will make sure that
I answer every question.
If not in house today, then
I'll answer them online.
So keep the link
to the Dory itself.
The instructions are
here on how to use it.
You use the app.
And you can see the links that
you're going to follow there.
And then you put your
questions into the Dory Q&A.
We actually had a
couple of questions
about an hour ago before
the session even began,
which I thought was really cool.
So thank you, whoever it was
that asked those questions.
And I've answered them already.
OK.
So we're going to talk
about machine learning.
And there's this ongoing
revolution that's
happening in machine learning.
And because of TensorFlow,
and because of how
we've open-sourced TensorFlow,
the goal behind that
is that you can be a
part of that revolution.
This isn't something
that we're just doing.
We've open-sourced
this platform.
We've worked with
lots of people.
lots of partners
to build some really
interesting scenarios.
But any one of these scenarios
is something that you can do.
And you're not going to
require great expertise
in machine learning or AI
or any of these things.
We're democratizing it to
make it easy for everybody.
But a couple of my favorite
examples that I want to share--
so first of all, I actually
studied physics in university.
And back when I was
going to university
was when they discovered the
first extrasolar planets.
And how the first extrasolar
planets were discovered
were by some of the best
astrophysicists in the world.
And what they were
doing was that they
were taking a look at stars.
And some stars-- very
distant, very large stars--
would have a slight
wobble in them.
And from time to time they
would see this star just
do a little wobble.
And they tried to figure out
what was causing that wobble.
And then they theorized, what if
there was a really big planet,
like a Jupiter or a Saturn,
orbiting close to that star?
Then what would happen is
the gravitational attraction
of the large massed planet
could cause a wobble in the star
itself.
And as a result we discovered
the first extrasolar planets.
But they were very
large planets that
were very close to
their parent stars.
In the 20-odd years
since then we've
discovered thousands and
thousands of planets.
And just in the last year,
through machine learning
and through machines being
able to spot patterns
in the behavior
of stars, not only
are we discovering
extrasolar planets,
but we're actually able to see
things like in the Kepler-90
system.
We're able to count the
planets that are in the star.
And the Kepler-90i-- this
planet is a small, rocky planet
which has got an orbital
period of only about 14 days.
So it's no longer limited to
large planets that are really
close to their host star.
We're actually being able
to map these solar systems.
And in the case of
the Kepler-90 system,
we've actually mapped
eight planets and what
the size of those
planets are, and then
through spectrographic
analysis actually
been able to identify
some of the materials
and the makeup of these planets.
Another example is in something
called diabetic retinopathy.
And diabetic retinopathy
is a very common disease.
And it can cause
blindness and worse
if it's not discovered early.
And if it's discovered
early, it's very cheap,
and it's very easy
to treat with drugs.
And some of the machine
learning research
that we've been working
on has actually,
through just simple
pictures of the cornea,
been able to spot
some of the markers
of diabetic retinopathy.
So it can be diagnosed early.
And it can be diagnosed
really cheaply.
And now we're lucky
enough, most of us,
to live in places with great
hospitals like San Francisco--
I'm from Seattle-- and
that kind of thing.
But there are parts of the world
that they don't have access
to this kind of
imaging equipment.
And we think, wouldn't
it be marvelous
that if someday and
someday very soon just
something cheap
like a cell phone--
that you will be able to do
the machine inference on a cell
phone to be able to take
a photo of a cornea,
load it into a cell phone,
and do a diagnosis right away.
Things like this we're
learning are beginning
to revolutionize health care.
And we've found some
of our results--
while some of the most skillful
ophthalmologists in the world
have like a 99%
hit rate in being
able to diagnose these
things, some machine
learning models that
we've been building
are actually doing the same.
They're equivalent and
sometimes even slightly better
than a human ophthalmologist.
Now, the idea here is not
to replace ophthalmologists.
The idea is to enhance
what they can do.
If an ophthalmologist can see
100 people in a day instead
of five people in a day by
using something like this,
everybody benefits.
Another one that I've
been really interested in
and I find fascinating
is an understanding
and being able to control the
deforestation of our planet.
And there have been some
machine-learned projects that
have been built where
what they've done--
I believe it was in
the Amazon rain forest
that they used old
Android phones.
You know those ones that you're
probably going to throw away?
And they've been
building TensorFlow
machine-learned models that
will spot the signs of logging.
And spotting the
signs of logging
can actually be very simple.
It's the sound of a chainsaw.
It's the sound of trees falling.
And by training a model
with those sounds,
by training a model
with those things
and putting it
onto a cell phone,
having that cell
phone be connected
and then spreading them
through the forest--
instead of having
people going and trying
to monitor to see where
illegal logging is going on,
these things, once they
detect it, they dial home.
And it's been cutting
illegal logging drastically.
Another personal
favorite of mine,
and this one's a
little bit more fun,
is being able to use
the Google Arts app.
And this you can download and
play with on the Play Store
right now.
All you've got to do
is you take a selfie.
And then what it will do is
based on the pattern of what
it sees in that selfie,
it will match your face
with famous works of art.
Like in this case, you can
see here this young lady.
She has very distinctive eyes.
And she's got a very
nice little smile.
And her eyes and smile get
matched very, very nicely
to paintings like
this one and this one.
And if you try it yourself,
it can be a lot of fun.
This morning I decided to sit
down and try it out for myself.
And I got this.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, to me, the guy on the right
looks more like John Cleese
than he looks like me.
But what can you do?
But then I thought, maybe I
can try to fool the algorithm.
So I decided to put a cup of
coffee in front of my face.
And I got this.
So I guess it thought the
beard and the cup of coffee
looked very similar.
You can have a whole
lot of fun with this.
And again, it uses
machine learning.
And the algorithm,
the model, has
been built using all
of this famous artwork.
And then what it does is
that when I take a selfie
it matches my face.
It extracts features
from my face,
and it tries to find artwork
with similar features.
And then it matches
me accordingly.
But what is machine learning?
You come to conferences
like this one.
You come to maybe Google I/O.
You go to AI conferences.
And you hear all
these great scenarios
about finding planets and curing
diseases and matching faces
with John Cleese or
John Cleese lookalikes.
But what actually
is machine learning?
So the way I like
to look at it is
if you think about-- how many of
us here are coders, by the way?
How many programmers are here?
Oh, good.
Most of us.
OK.
So classical programming,
when we think about it,
is you think about classical
programming as a black box.
And you put data and you put
rules into that black box.
And you get answers out of it.
So if I were to
think about-- say
if I'm building something
that's like a dogs versus cats
classifier.
That would be really
difficult, right?
How do you tell the difference
between a dog and a cat?
You know, cats might
have pointy ears.
And they're planning
to murder you.
Dogs probably have
long floppy tongues.
And they'll love you for
the rest of your life.
But those things are
really hard to do in rules.
Right?
Those things are
hard to do in coding.
And most of us who are classical
programmers-- we've used Java,
we've used C# or C++ or
any of these things--
that's what we do.
We write rules.
If this, then that.
While this, do that.
All of those kinds of things.
And then those worlds
operate on data.
We compile them into
something of value.
And that something of value
gives us what we need.
That gives us the answers out.
Well, all machine learning
is, and the revolution
around machine learning, is it
flips the axis on this diagram.
So machine learning is
you put the answers in,
you put the data in, and
you get the rules out.
So it may not seem like much.
But when you start thinking
about some of the scenarios
that now become possible--
I'm wearing a
smartwatch at the moment
which tracks my activity.
This watch knows
when I'm walking.
It knows when I'm running.
It knows when I'm swimming--
in my case probably trying
not to drown.
And it can detect
all of these things.
But think about
walking and running.
Now, if you're a classical
programmer, how would
you tell the difference
when somebody
is wearing a watch between
walking and running?
Maybe it's based on their speed.
You could somehow be able
to infer the speed based
on the location of the watch.
Maybe if the watch has
a heart rate sensor
it'd be based on
their heart rates.
But some people when
they're running probably
have a much lower heart rate
than I have when I'm walking.
And how do you tell the
difference between when
I'm walking and running?
There are some times if
I'm going really fast I
might be walking downhill.
And sometimes if I'm
going really slow
I might be running uphill.
So all these if-thens-- it
becomes very, very difficult
to build something like
an activity tracker
like I have on this watch.
But with machine
learning, you say, OK.
I'm not going to
write if-then rules.
I'm going to give it
all of the answers.
When Apple created this watch--
and they've been doing it with
the recognition on this watch--
they've had thousands of people
exercising and saying, OK.
Right now I'm running.
Right now I'm walking.
Right now I'm swimming.
And from that they've
been able to build models.
And anybody who builds any
kind of activity recognition
does the same thing.
So now you're feeding into
this thing all the answers.
This is what walking looks like.
This is what running looks like.
This is what
swimming looks like.
And you feed it in the data.
This is what it looks like.
And as a result, when you
build a model around that,
then out of that
will come the rules.
So now in future if you pass it
a bunch of data, it will say,
I think you're walking.
I think you're running.
I think you're swimming.
And that's the whole
revolution in machine learning.
It's not a lot when
you think about it.
When you look at
the two diagrams
they don't look very different.
So what I always
encourage people to do
is think about the scenarios
that this empowers.
Think about, for example,
the planet spotting
that I spoke about earlier on.
That would not be easy
to do with if-then rules.
It would be possible.
But it's a lot of code
that you have to write.
It's a lot of code that
you have to maintain.
And then when you get new
data in that breaks the rules,
you probably have to
rewrite the rules.
Think about things like
the diabetic retinopathy--
the same thing.
So when we talk about TensorFlow
and when we're building out
TensorFlow, we always ask people
to just remember this diagram.
This is all about you
getting your data,
understanding your data,
getting the answers--
that's called
labeling the data--
and then having a
framework that will
allow you to munge them
together and build something
that will give you inference.
So that you give it
future data and then
it will tell you what the
class of that data is.
So now there's a whole
bunch of products
that we've built at Google.
You've probably
seen a bunch of them
this morning in the keynote.
And I just wanted to
highlight one here.
So the idea behind
these is that we've
been working on this
stuff for years.
We've been working on how
to build something that
provides great inference, that
provides for great machine
learning.
And on top of that we've built
some products so that if there
are some scenarios that you want
to do-- like face detection,
logo identification, label
identification, et cetera--
then there's a product like
Cloud Vision that does it.
But these aren't
different products.
Cloud Vision is built
on top of TensorFlow.
So TensorFlow is the
framework that I've mentioned.
If you're not familiar
with it, it's open source.
It's free.
You can go download it
and you can play with it.
And we define it as the machine
learning platform for everybody
to solve real problems.
So I just wanted to set
the level of where we're
at for this session before
I start going into some
of the new stuff and what
we've been working on
in the last year.
So here's where we've been
going in the last 12 months.
So first of all, the number
one piece of feedback
that we've had from
software developers was,
would you please
support my language?
I love TensorFlow.
I love machine learning.
I'm not a Pythonista.
I really want to be able to
use things such as Swift.
Or I really want to be able to
use things such as JavaScript.
And as a result, these
are two of the things
that we've been working
hard to add to the platform.
I'm going to be showing
some JavaScript stuff later.
And I'm also doing a session
immediately after this one--
and I can't remember if it's
upstairs or downstairs--
upstairs in the 3,000s.
And I'll be showing some
JavaScript demos there.
So the idea is as a software
developer JavaScript
is a skill.
It's a highly
sought after skill.
And it's a very common skill.
And we really wanted to
bring these scenarios
of being able to
do machine learning
to JavaScript developers.
Because then two
things can happen.
Number one, you can actually
execute models directly
in the browser.
And number two, you can
even train models directly
in the browser.
There's a really
cool demo if you
go to js.tensorflow.org
where it's a Pac-Man game.
And if you've ever seen the
Google Doodle of Pac-Man,
if you remember that one, you
can actually train Pac-Man
based on the webcam.
So you can point up, point
down, point left, point right.
And then you can control
Pac-Man that way.
It's all done
within the browser.
So there's no
round-tripping of code
to Google or anywhere else.
All of the training is done
in the browser of the model.
You're passing it in the
answers by saying this is up.
You're passing it in
the data by frames
of your finger pointing up.
And then you train the model.
And it only takes a few seconds.
It's really cool stuff.
But this then opens up
several different scenarios
for machine learning.
And the direction
that we've been
trying to take with TensorFlow
is really threefold.
So number one, there's
TensorFlow itself.
So there's the main
framework of TensorFlow.
And this is designed to
allow you to train models
and to execute models
on a variety of devices.
So what that provides you
is the APIs and the SDKs
and the ability
to take the data,
take the labels or the
answers into that data,
compile a model, and then
run inference on that model
in a variety of places, serving
it off of a web browser, et
cetera, et cetera.
But in addition to that this
year we've been focusing very
hard-- and it's part
of my core passion--
on something called
TensorFlow Lite.
And the idea behind
TensorFlow Lite
is that this is just for
executing models and running
inference.
And it allows you to do it
on a variety of devices--
so Android, iOS.
You've probably seen we've run
some demos on Raspberry Pi.
And we're working
on more IoT devices.
We'll have some announcements
about that shortly.
So the idea here
is that sometimes
training a model you need a
big expensive workstation.
You need maybe TPUs or
GPUs to train something.
But you want to be able to
distribute that model to people
to be able to use it anywhere.
Like the diabetic retinopathy
I spoke about earlier on--
wouldn't it be great if
places in the emerging
world with a cheap
cell phone could just
have a simple app with a
model running on that app?
And then they pass a photograph
of the cornea of an eye
into it.
And then it will run
inference on that
and give you a prediction
about whether this person has
diabetic retinopathy or not.
That's the idea behind
TensorFlow Lite--
to be able to take these
big models that you
build on workstations
but take them out
of the big enterprises, take
them out of the universities,
and give developers an
opportunity to build something
that thousands of people
use, millions of people
can use, and to
change the world.
So that's our goal
behind TensorFlow Lite.
Now, notice that's
just the run time.
You're not going be doing
any training on the devices.
Because they've got
relatively less power.
And then thirdly
is TensorFlow.js.
So this is JavaScript.
And as I mentioned earlier
on, here's a case of now
if you want to distribute
training to people--
the nice thing
about web technology
is with a web browser,
you type in a url
and your application executes
within that person's browser.
What if you have
a scenario where
people want to give you data?
Or you want to train a
model off of people's data
and off of the labels
that they give.
You can now distribute
the gathering
of this data over the web.
Either train it directly within
their browser or, of course,
have them send it back to
you where you can train it
by working in JavaScript.
And another nice
part about being
able to do this in
JavaScript is-- does anybody
use Cloud Functions?
A few.
Or Cloud Functions for Firebase?
OK.
So as you know,
they run in Node.js.
And if it runs in Node.js, now
by having JavaScript on there
you can actually
execute a function
to either run inference
on a machine-learned model
or to build a
machine-learned model.
The nice thing about
Cloud Functions
is that they operate
off of triggers,
where a trigger is something
happening in your network
or something happening
in your system.
For example, if a user
logs into your application,
that's a trigger.
So instead of you explicitly
calling a piece of code,
you could say this has
triggered this code to execute.
And you then may have
a scenario where,
OK, a user has logged in.
I want to run an inference,
maybe to do something
like a capture, automatically
behind the scenes-- those kind
of things.
There's lots of scenarios.
It's up to you to think of
what would work best for you.
So as I mentioned, one
of my passions is mobile.
And so I'd like to talk a little
bit about TensorFlow Lite.
So this is what
it's like to use it.
So this is Java code
running on Android.
So if you're a
Kotlinista as well,
if you like Kotlin, of course
this will work in Kotlin.
If you're an iOS developer,
right now it only works in C++.
We haven't built the projections
into Objective-C or Swift
yet for it.
So you'd have to write
C++ to do the inference.
But we're working on that.
But all you have to
do is very simply
there is a package called
org.tensorflow.lite.interpreter.
And on this one you
would load your model.
So earlier I spoke
about building a model.
You give it answers.
You give it data.
It gives you rules.
You compile that model
using TensorFlow.
That model from TensorFlow then,
to be able to run on mobile,
uses a process
called flattening.
The idea is you take
that and it flattens it.
And it makes it more compact.
And it removes some of
the larger floating point
operations and stuff like that.
It makes it smaller so it
will run on a mobile device.
And the file extension
for that is .tflite.
Which is why you see here
new Interpreter("awesome
model.tflite").
And then all you
have to do with that
is you pass it your inputs.
And it gives you
back the outputs.
So for example-- I don't know.
If you're writing a
classifier like I mentioned
for a diabetic
retinopathy, your input
would be your
image or how you've
processed that image so that
the model would recognize it.
And your outputs that
it would give you back
would be a probability of this
person having that disease.
[COUGHS]
Excuse me.
The performance of TensorFlow
Lite is actually really nice.
As you can see here,
we did this benchmark.
And there's famous machine
learning models called
MobileNet and
Inception which are
used for image classification.
And when we flattened
the model, when
we ran it on TensorFlow
Lite on an Android device
or on an iOS device and we
did some benchmarking in Q1
of this year, these are
the performance increases
that we've actually seen.
So the orange bar is
running it on TensorFlow
on a traditional workstation.
The gray bar is running it on
TensorFlow Lite on a mobile.
And we can see that
inference is very, very fast.
And I'm going to show a
demo in a moment of me doing
a live image classification.
And you'll see how fast that
it will actually execute.
Actually, I'll do it right now.
So if we can switch
to the demo machine.
So I need to sign in.
Sorry.
OK.
So I am actually going to run
this in the Android emulator,
which I know is incredibly
brave of me, live on stage.
So as you'll see it's running.
So I'm running the
Android emulator here.
And you can see the webcam on
the Android Emulator is going.
And it's actually
classifying three things.
So what's happening is this is--
MobileNet has been trained with
a thousand different images.
So there's a neural
network that's
been trained to
detect a thousand
different types of image.
So what happens is
now every time it's
capturing a frame
from the webcam,
or from the front cam on
the emulated phone, what
it's actually doing
is it's passing that
to this compiled model.
This compiled model
is coming back then
with a set of probabilities
of each of these 1,000.
So like right now, I'm
not showing it a banana.
So it's setting at a
probability of less than .011%
that it's a banana.
And then I'm taking
the top three
that it actually gave me back
and then representing them.
So we have this grid
on the wall behind us.
Obviously it hasn't
been trained for that.
But that kind of
looks like a strainer.
And as a result, it's saying,
hey, that's a strainer.
As you can see then
above that, that 1,385
milliseconds-- that's
the amount of time
it's taken to do the inference.
But consider that
that's actually
running on the emulator on
my desktop as I'm speaking.
[LAUGHTER]
What?
Did it say something funny?
Sometimes it says
dachshund or something
when I step in front of it.
Let's see.
I'm an Italian Greyhound.
Yay!
[LAUGHTER]
I wish I was that fast.
But like if I--
if you're familiar with "Silicon
Valley" and the hot dog,
not hot dog thing.
I don't know how it
will work in this light.
So we'll see.
But this is my
famous banana demo.
But let's see if it
says it's a banana.
There we go!
100% probability
that it was a banana.
I had to put this behind.
I was cheating.
The MobileNet model is a famous
model amongst researchers.
They've taken a thousand images.
We've built this neural
network that can then classify
amongst those thousand images.
Strainer, shower
curtain, and all those
are three of those images.
Banana and Italian
greyhound are others.
And this is now running on
Android as you can see here.
And it's doing pretty well.
It's only taking like
1,100 milliseconds
to actually identify something
when running on an emulator.
I also have this running on my--
I have a Pixel 2 phone.
I have it running on my phone.
If you see me later and you want
to see a demo of how fast it
is on actual hardware-- then it
can do this inference usually
in 50 milliseconds or less.
So if we can switch back
to the slides, please.
I'm a keyboard.
I'm a sock.
I'm a strainer.
I'm a running shoe.
Yeah.
Can we switch back to the
slides please, before I
embarrass myself further?
I'm a hamster!
So the next one
that I mentioned--
remember, there were
three run times.
There's TensorFlow.
There's TensorFlow Lite.
And then there's TensorFlow.js.
So with TensorFlow.js,
the idea is
that we've been working hard.
We released this in
March of this year.
And we see the two
main scenarios for this
as, number one, to be able
to do training or inference
within the browser.
It takes advantage of
things such as WebGL
when it's running
in the browser.
So it can be very, very fast.
And then on the other side
of it, if you have servers
and you want to execute
stuff on a Node.js server,
be that something like
a Cloud Function or just
your own Node.js server,
then you can do so as well.
And the really neat thing, like
I've mentioned, about this--
and I've know I'm repeating
myself, but it is really cool--
is the fact that you can do
both training and inference.
So you can actually present
somebody with a web page.
They give you data.
And it will train a model
based on their data.
And then they can execute
inference on that.
Or you can build a model,
such as the MobileNet
model that I've mentioned,
which is the one that I just
used for the image
classification,
download to that
browser, and then retrain
the final layer of that with
classifications of their own.
And that's how the
Pac-Man demo works.
If you go to
js.tensorflow.org and take
a look at the Pac-Man
demo, that will
be trained with four new
classes of image-- one for up,
one for down, one for
left, one for right.
You can do it however you like.
I tend to use my
finger for training it.
Or some people will actually
look up, look down, look left,
look right.
And while it's a fun little
demo, think about the impact
that that could have on
things such as accessibility.
You know, sometimes we build
accessibility into products.
But the accessibility tends to
be a common solution for the--
I don't want to use the term
lowest common denominator,
but you know what I mean--
for the mass denominator
in this case.
But it might be that
for an individual
the accessibility
might work differently.
Maybe they want to scroll
by going like this.
I don't know.
Or scroll by nodding their head.
But you could actually
use an image classifier
in the browser,
retrained in the browser,
for different, say, scroll or
click or something like that.
So that accessibility
could be customized
to a particular user.
These are the kind of scenarios
that are now becoming possible.
We can't build them all.
We can't even think of them all.
And that's why we like to talk
about TensorFlow with folks
like you.
I know there are people
in this audience right now
who've got fabulous scenarios.
And they just haven't had the
tools with which to build them.
And we're hoping that the
tools that we're building
will unblock you from
being able to do that.
So coding.
So perhaps the biggest
changes in TensorFlow,
as well as adding this new
stuff, is in some of the coding
that we've been able to provide.
So if you've been a TensorFlow
developer up to now,
and you are a developer
rather than an academic,
if you've come from a
development background,
then the coding of
TensorFlow models
might have seemed a
little alien to you.
The idea was you define a model.
You end up doing something
called building a graph.
You build everything
ahead of time.
And then you execute the
graph to do the training.
As software developers--
I don't know about you.
I can't write more than
three lines of code
without having a bug in it.
And as a result, I like to
write code two or three lines
at a time, run them, test them,
write the next two or three
lines, run them, test them.
And that's traditional
programming.
And that didn't really work
very well with TensorFlow.
So we have something that
we put into TensorFlow
which I'm going to show.
Actually, I went to
the last one first.
We put something into TensorFlow
that we called eager execution.
And the idea behind
eager execution
is what that gives
you is the ability
to be like a pure
Python programmer
but continue to build
TensorFlow models.
You get things such as
step-by-step debugging.
You get the immediacy of
being a real Python developer.
And then also as you're
building your models, if you're
familiar with things
such as gradient descent,
and there's differentiation
and math that
needs to be done
to determine loss
and all that kind of
thing-- you don't lose that.
There's something called
a gradient tape in there.
And based on the named tape,
if you're from the VHS world
like I used to be, the idea
is that's recording everything
on tape.
And that tape you can go back
and forward and all that kind
of stuff.
So it's like you're not
losing any of the value
that you had when you were
building graph-based stuff
by changing to immediacy because
things such as a gradient tape
are there.
But let me skip back.
So the other big
change, and to me
the other really
exciting big change,
is in how you build models.
So we've been working
really closely with Keras.
And Francois Chollet,
who invented Keras,
now works for Google.
And he works on our team.
And so he has been
bringing Keras
to TensorFlow and the
tf.keras namespace.
And if you've done
any construction
of neural networks, if
you've done anything
like that, if you want
to get into the really
complicated stuff,
the idea behind Keras
is that it makes it really easy.
Now, some of the terms
that you see on the slide
here, if you're not a
neural network person,
may seem unintuitive to you.
And I'm really sorry about that.
But the idea is when
you think about it, when
you define a neural
network, generally
you're defining
layers of neurons.
And then in each
layer of neurons
you're defining behaviors.
And in those behaviors,
there's generally two things
that you define.
One is called an
activation function.
And this is what it takes to
actually activate that neuron
and how it behaves
when it is activated.
And the other one is
called a loss function.
And this is what
type of function
am I going to use to
minimize loss in this layer.
If you're not a neural
network person, sorry.
A lot of that would be
kind of gibberish to you.
But the code to do
this was actually
very complicated before Keras.
And with Keras here,
here's how I can now
define a neural network.
I'm defining it and
it's just like, hey, I'm
creating a sequential network.
So I have a number
of layers and they're
operating in a sequence.
Here's my shape of
my input, 28 by 28.
My first layer of
my network-- well,
this is what it's going to be.
It's a convolutional,
two-dimensional one.
And my activation in this
is something called a ReLu.
And I'll continue to define
my network like that.
This kind of code to be able
to define a network like this
might have taken dozens, if
not hundreds, of lines of code
previously.
But with Keras, as you can
see, if you're a neural network
person, it's intuitive to you.
If you are just learning
this for the first time,
a lot of these terms will
seem very difficult to you.
But actually as
you start learning
and as you start
growing in it, you'll
see that this has actually
really simplified it for you.
Think about it in terms of
object-oriented development.
You're creating an
object, which is
your sequential neural network.
And you're setting
properties on that.
You're saying this
layer looks like this
and has this function.
This layer looks like this
And it's really
as simple as that.
Then there's input processing.
The most important
thing when you're
defining a neural
network is you've
got to feed it good data.
If you remember
my diagram earlier
on where I said you give it
data and you give it answers
and it infers the rules, you've
got to give it good data.
Garbage in, garbage out.
Or if you remember
Johnny 5, "need input."
So being able to
give it good data--
you need to be able to have
the tools to define your data,
to take dirty data that you
might have and clean it,
or to have tools to
take data that you have
and do things like normalize it
or make it easier to understand
for neural network.
And then also, more
importantly, if you're
building giant neural networks
that take a lot of training,
as you're feeding data in
you want to be efficient.
If you feed in a
terabyte of data
and then wait 100
hours for it to train,
and then you have
another terabyte of data
and you wait 100
hours for it to train,
that's not very efficient.
So there's a concept
called data pipelines
where you can optimize
your input of data
to the time it takes
to train the data.
And we've been building
that out in something
called the tf.data namespace.
So instead of you just
taking random data
in a data structure like NumPy
or lists in Swift or something
along those lines, if you
actually take your data
and you format it with
the tf.data namespace,
it's synchronized
with the training.
As a result, you can make
your input data and training
pipeline much more efficient.
So eager I've
mentioned earlier on.
So now the next
thing is we've been
working really hard on these
things called Cloud TPUs.
So T in TPU stands for Tensor.
So the name TensorFlow comes
from the flow of tensors
through a network.
And tensors are a way that
you can define your data
so that they're optimized
for neural networks
and for neural networks
to process them.
So we said we wanted
to build a chip that's
designed specifically
for processing tensors.
And that's why we came
up with this thing
that we call the TPU, the
Tensor Processing Unit.
They are highly, highly, highly
optimized for TensorFlow.
And as a result, you can see
some of the data about this
here.
It's high bandwidth memory.
There's 180 teraflops
per device, which
apparently is quite a lot.
But I'd rather look
at the results.
Oh, sorry.
Before I go to them, I'd like
to use an analogy for that.
So think about when you're
training a neural network
on your laptop or
on your desktop PC.
That probably has a CPU.
And a CPU, the
idea behind that is
that's a chip that's designed
for processing anything.
It's designed for managing
the windows on your screen.
It's designed for
your networking stack.
all of these things.
And it's a little bit
like a Swiss army knife.
It's designed to be
able to do everything.
But it's not particularly
optimized for anything.
So as a result, it's not
optimized for training
and machine learning.
And maybe you want
to build a model.
And that model might take you
a month to build on a CPU.
Or it might take a year,
depending on the amount
of data that you have.
So the idea with a TPU is that
it's a highly optimized, highly
focused knife.
It's like a sushi chef's knife.
So if you've ever
known a sushi chef,
or if you've ever sat at a bar
where the people are making
sushi, they have these highly
optimized, highly sharp knives
that they can use to cut the
fish without taking bones
and all of those kind
of things with it.
And I always like to say--
people go, why would
I want to use a TPU?
Why would I want
to pay for a TPU?
And think about
it in those terms.
If you need to train a model
and you've got a lot of data
to train that model
on, like the thousands
or hundreds of thousands of
hours it takes to do something
like activity
recognition on a watch,
you want that training
to happen quickly.
And you want it to be
optimized for actually
training that model.
And so I always
like to say, well,
if you're going to
use a CPU, you're
using a Swiss army knife to make
sushi, which you don't really
want to do.
So taking one common
model called ResNet
for image classification,
here's some of the results
that we got from
using a TPU on it.
So the number of
images per second
being fed in using
tf.data were about 2,700.
And synthetic
images-- so the idea
was you take in
the real image, we
do some processing on that
to make a synthetic image,
and then they were being fed in.
It was over 3,000 per second.
And we found that we were able
to train it to 76% accuracy--
so that is, when you
do the classification,
like I was doing earlier on,
it's right 76% of the time--
on ImageNet.
But doing this on a TPU,
on a Tensor Processing
Unit, the cost for doing
this was actually about $85
when we did this.
Now compare that to if
you were to buy a GPU,
or many universities who
are renting access to GPUs.
The cost used to be in the
tens of thousands of dollars.
They've brought it down to
the thousands of dollars.
There was one experiment-- we
designed this slide actually
for a presentation that Jeff
Dean was giving back in April.
And we put it with $85 on there.
Before he went on stage,
somebody did another test.
And they actually had it
significantly lower than that.
I'm not allowed
to say the number.
But the point is it's
actually going down sharply.
So think about building a
really, really complex model.
You're talking about now it
can cost in the tens of dollars
instead of in the
thousands or hundreds
of thousands of dollars.
And if you take a
look at this link
you can actually see
the benchmark submission
that we put in at Stanford.
So some of the other things that
we've been trying to do is that
as TensorFlow is moving
towards version 1.10 very soon,
it's now time to bring more
developers into the fold.
It's becoming less of an
academic infrastructure
and academic framework.
And we're trying to make it
more and more developer friendly
so developers can start
building real things with it--
things such as the cell
phone that I spoke about
and scenarios with that one.
And as a result, we launched
a blog on blog.tensorflow.org.
And we launched a
YouTube channel.
I personally run
the YouTube channel.
So if you've got any ideas
for videos or any questions
you'll see me all over that one.
And please reach out.
I'm happy to create any videos
for scenarios that you want
to see and want to learn about.
Also what we've been trying
to do is to empower everybody
to learn and explore
machine learning
through something called the
Machine Learning Crash Course.
And it's this link
at the bottom here--
g.co/machinelearningcrashcourse.
It's a place where
you can learn it.
And I'm not trying to
be salesman-y about it
or anything, but
this was the course
that we built to train us.
So I learned machine learning--
I used to work on
Firebase at Google.
I learned machine
learning while I
was on the Firebase team
using the internal version
of this course.
So this is what we've used
to train the actual Google
engineers who are
building the thing.
So some other things that
we've been working on--
TensorFlow Hub is the next one.
So if you think
about models, there
are common scenarios for
models like image recognition
or translation or
text classification.
So we said, we want to be able
to create a hub where people
can download those models and
use them, and maybe even use
parts of them in
their own models.
If you're familiar
with TensorFlow,
a lot of the models that we've
done we've just put on GitHub.
And you know, GitHub is great.
You can download a model off
of that and you can use it.
But it's not optimized
for something like this.
It's not a catalog.
It's not searchable.
It's not easy for everybody
to share in one place.
So the idea is that we wanted
to build TensorFlow Hub,
or TF-Hub as we call it,
so that you can find models
that you can reuse.
You can find models
that you can build on,
or of course, you can
share your own models.
And again it's at that
url, tensorflow.org/hub.
So one of the things that's
kind of coming in the future--
we're still working hard on it--
that we're really
passionate about now
is what we call learn
to learn, or AutoML.
And the idea is we said, OK.
Well, what if today you
want to build a solution?
What do you need?
You need machine
learning expertise.
You need people who
understand Python or whatever
the language--
whatever languages I was
talking about earlier-- can do.
You need them to be able
to understand the data,
how to format the data and
put that into pipelines,
how to design a neural network.
It's a lot of expertise.
Of course you would
need all the data.
And you also need the
computation power.
This is what the world
looks like today if you
want to build a good solution.
We said, what if we could
take the deep ML expertise out
of that and just say
data plus lots and lots
and lots of computation?
Because machine
learning, after all,
is you feed it in the answers,
you feed it in the data,
and it comes up with
an inference from it.
So if you remember this slide
that I showed you earlier on--
I've been working on TensorFlow
for about six months.
I still don't understand half
of the words on this slide.
Not many people do.
I don't know why,
for example, I would
use a MaxPooling of (2,2),
(2,2) instead of (3,3), (3,3),
other than a lot
of experimentation,
a lot of trial,
and a lot of error.
There are people who can
understand a neural network
and understand the math
behind a neural network
and who may be able to write
better code than I would here.
But a lot of the time when
I'm building something
like this it's a lot
of trial and error.
It's a lot of, OK, where
am I going to flatten it?
Where am I going to do dropouts?
Where am I going to do
all these kind of things?
And there's a bit of a black
box element in designing
these neural networks.
There are academic
papers coming out
on a daily basis that
say, well, if you want
to do image recognition, you
should do this many dropouts
or you should do
that many dropouts.
Or you should use a ReLu or
you should use something else.
It's not as prescriptive as--
well, in many ways it could be.
I was about to say it's not
as prescriptive as writing
typical code.
But then sometimes-- well, is
it better to do a for loop?
Is it better to do a while loop?
These kind of things
are typical of code.
And it's the same
kind of thing that
will happen when you're
designing neural networks.
Should I design it with
this number of input layers
or this type of function?
So we said, well, what if
with this kind of code,
instead of a human doing a lot
of trial and error behind that,
we actually have a
computer do the trial
and error behind that?
Then we say, OK.
We know roughly what our neural
network should look like.
And we know roughly what
kind of activation functions
should be on there and
what kind of dropouts
and all that kind of stuff.
And what if we then, say, take
that and then train on that,
but then we try lots
of different ones?
We change the function here.
We change the design
of a layer there,
all these kind of things.
And we iterate and
iterate and iterate.
And then we evaluate
those models.
Then we could actually have a
computer learning how to learn.
We could actually build a
machine learning kind of thing
that learns how to learn.
Now, the computational
expense for this
is really, really
big right now, which
is probably why Google are
the only ones doing it.
But with Moore's Law
being Moore's Law,
it's getting cheaper over time.
And as a result, we can
actually start thinking about,
in the future, building
neural architectures that
optimize themselves.
So some of the results that
we've had out of this is that
when we take a look at some of
the hand-crafted models that
are out there, that
have been built by some
of the world's
greatest researchers--
if you take a look
at the x-axis here,
the x-axis here is the number
of operations of computation
that are needed.
Just see that as the
expense, ultimately,
even though that expense
is coming down over time.
And the y-axis is the accuracy
and precision of these image
recognition models.
So if we take a
look at something
like Inception, which you
can see in the lower left,
that's a very cheap
and very easy model.
And the accuracy of
it is around 70%.
Or MobileNet, which
is the one that I
was using when I was
classifying on my phone,
you can see it's a
pretty cheap model.
And the accuracy is about 70%.
But when we start looking
at all the research that's
been done on this, and we go
all the way over to the right,
you can see that the cost of
that is orders of magnitude
higher.
But the actual accuracy isn't.
It's going to 80% or
82% instead of 70%.
So we said, OK.
What if we can compare a
network that learns itself
rather than something that was
designed by a human to this?
And this is what we got.
So when we started
training on small models,
as you can see on
the left, we actually
knocked things like MobileNet
and Inception out of the water.
So for the same cost we had
far more accurate models.
And then when we go
over onto the right
we're in the same ballpark,
if not slightly better.
So for really, really large
data sets and really, really--
so instead of 1,000 images,
maybe 100,000 images
it's able to
classify-- we've been
able to find that we're
in the same ballpark
by having these networks.
Instead of a human
designing this network
and testing this network
and figuring it out,
the human gives us the base
that we're going to start from.
But then it learns and it
improves itself over time.
And if you remember
the AlphaGo that
beat Lee Sedol, the
champion, but then there
was another version
of AlphaGo which
learned by itself that beat
the one that beat Lee Sedol--
it's the same kind of technology
that was in use there.
So just going back to some
of the impact you can have--
and we've been working
on it and learn
to learn for the diabetic
retinopathy as well.
Again, comparing with humans--
taking humans and
the data that humans
have been able to give us to
train a model but then using
learn to learn to
improve on that model.
That's where we've been
getting the results
in diabetic retinopathy
that are actually
improving over what the top
ophthalmologists can do.
And again, I just
want to reiterate
this is not a replacement
for ophthalmologists.
The goal here is that if an
ophthalmologist can manually
do this and see
five people a day,
but if they have
a tool like this
that allows them to see 100
people a day, everybody wins.
So with that in mind, just
remember the whole goal
and the whole revolution
of machine learning
is you put your answers
in, you put your data in,
and you get your rules out.
And as a programmer,
if you're switching
that pivot from
what you've done,
it opens up these massive,
massive new scenarios for you
that you can provide value for
yourself, for your business,
and for the world at large.
So that's our goal
with TensorFlow.
And that's what we've been
working on in the last year.
Our goal ultimately is to
make machines intelligent
and to improve people's lives.
[MUSIC PLAYING]